okay we're back
oh wait I forgot to switch everything
over hold on a
[Laughter]
[Music]
second
okay all right y'all we're officially
back we are officially back all right
let me grab uh show you guys what we've
been working on let me
grab
uh download Discord on
here I never I never use this computer
man like I haven't used this thing in
forever like I have to set up Discord on
this I have to like install Discord
like
like I'm just installing this damn thing
in real
time okay but yeah so here's the thing
before we start Spider-Man um a lot of
you guys have been asking where geek
culture explained is what it is that
happened to geek culture explained and
at the moment we are actually going to
Rebrand it because we are working on
something so this thing that we are
working
on I will show
you like right
now uh
okay let me double
check actually we'll download this real
quick download anyway 600
megabytes now I've never actually
brought a file in to obs in order to
play as like an actual mp4 file and uh
fingers crossed YouTube doesn't decide
to just shut the stream down because you
guys know how YouTube is Right There
YouTube loves stomping on people's fun
so we are going
[Music]
to add a media
Source browse
downloads wait a
minute
where is
this really that's still a
thing
okay
let's mute the live gamer for right
now
uh
settings audio or uh audio there we go
desktop
audio I think it's high definition audio
device
uh there we
go
okay Advanced
properties okay um so you guys should
only be able to hear me right
now all right you guys can only hear
me okay okay
cool
uh
yes all right let's
add window
capture no we don't want to do
that
I have news Lois is pregnant how did you
you're sweating your pupils are dilated
and your left hand is shaking you don't
that kind of bounced in like super fast
so hold
on
uh
okay what was that were you did you guys
hear that were you guys able to hear it
no we're not playing Destiny did you
guys hear the
audio okay
cool then we will go back to that media
source
I have news Lois is pregnant how did you
you're sweating your pupils are dilated
and your left hand is shaking you don't
usually show any outward signs of stress
or
fear the last time I saw you this afraid
you were facing
doomsday and I doubt it's
doomsday you're grinning like an idiot
we want you to be the
Godfather h
hey look at that the world's greatest
detective is
surprised I heard it's heartbeat
Bruce Lois
aaby stay away from
them time to go we're just going to
leave but this is the first submarine
I've ever owned we'll get you another
one I can't just get another one I've
named this one you can't abandon
something once it has a name everyone
knows
thatle any minute now Angry do gooders
are going to realize what we're up to if
we're still here when they arrive they
will hit us over and over again say
goodbye to your submarine goodbye
Gunter gter is a terrible name for a
submarine wait scarecrow's fear
toxin where is she choker come on batsy
use that pointy head of
yours you can see the
truth you just don't want to look at it
too hard what did you do to her you know
what I did I operated on her she's the
trigger when her heart stops every heart
in Metropolis stops
too why would her the Kryptonite
scarecrow added it to his fear toxin so
it could enter Superman's bloodstream
through his
lungs and then
Superman Superman can you hear me you
won't take them away from me Superman
son
whatever you're seeing it isn't real
it's
Lois it's
Lois
[Applause]
boom why this has always been about us
why why did you do this to
him every time you and I play I lose I
was getting a bit bored of always
losing I thought I'd try this on easy
mode for a
bit and it
was I can't show
everything I had to end it I know you
guys are pissed you guys are like
no oh man oh man but yeah
so yeah so
so this is this is what we're doing on
geek culture explain or what we will be
doing we haven't made it live yet but
we've got
uh we've got we've got goodies coming
down the pipe so yeah yeah yeah so we've
got goodies coming
but yeah you
monster I'm a terrible person I know I'm
a terrible person I'm a terrible person
I'm terrible okay uh let's get ourselves
online let's get this game going because
I'm G be honest with you guys man I am
absolutely jonesing for this I'm dying
for
this okay I do need to uh grab some
water what am I doing uh
Network wait a minute I can't let you
guys see my
network I can't let you guys see my
network I can't let you guys see this
stuff but let me know what you guys
think about that whole thing with uh
with Injustice Gods Among
Us like I'm I'm really curious to see
what you guys
think like it's your your opinion on
this matters a lot to me
so
okay give me one second guys let me grab
some water and
uh we will get this game playay going
because I am I am very excited about
this give me one second
guys
for
e
okay this live
stream is not brought to you by
Lark but I will drink from a lar bottle
anyway I got my laptop because my
phone's about to die so I will not be
able to see what people are saying so
let us fire up this
stream or at least load this thing
up so we can see what's going
on I like how the thumbnail for this
thing is
uh hold on is this only streaming in
1080P why is it only streaming in
1080 it it should be streaming in
uh should be streaming in
4k are you guys only showing
Reverb hold on is there is there
Reverb
uh
1080 yeah I should be streaming at
4K
uh yeah it should it should definitely
be streaming at
4K somebody's saying huge ver Reverb
somebody's saying no Reverb what Reverb
no Reverb okay then the Reverb problem
is
you if you're hearing Reverb that's
that's that's a you issue not a me issue
okay um hold on a
second I'm still here I'm just uh video
output is currently active oh okay
well yeah that's kind of that's that
kind of irritates me like I'm I wanted
this to be in uh
4K
yeah it was supposed to be 4K
6 okay I just uh switched it over to 4K
so if you guys uh if you guys hit
refresh um then you guys should be able
to
see the
stream you should be able to see the
stream at
4K how come I can't see the stream at
4K maybe it'll take a minute to load
up that kind of
sucks
output yeah it says it's streaming at
4K oh okay you're showing okay you're
showing 4K okay cool awesome okay um so
I currently have a single monitor set up
uh in terms of where my camera
replacement is is it good it's hopefully
it's not intrusive or anything like that
um but I do only have a single monitor
set up so if you guys need me to like
make changes with the audio or anything
like that
um
then yeah
uh you're watching on your phone don't
worry about it okay
cool okay what's my favorite MC see
movie um Captain America and the Winter
Soldier hands down hands down and
YouTube definitely allows you to stream
at 4K
so
uh yeah YouTube definitely allows you to
do
that that's just so weird that it's
stuck at
1080 like it's just it's it's just gonna
it's going to gripe me like it's just
gonna irritate
me like it's gonna irritate the heck out
of
me oh well I guess it is what it is
okay uh for me at 7:30
p.m okay
um all right audio is
good uh are you guys able to hear the
game audio and everything
there we
go I had my thing plugged into my
headphone it's a habit at this point
so okay uh let's switch this
over let's get to
playing
all
[Applause]
right can I show the Spider-Man statue
um I will here in a minute but I'm ready
to play this game man like I'm dying to
play this game we were supposed to start
an hour and a half ago right
like
[Music]
excited
all right is the game audio too
[Music]
loud game is a bit too loud
okay uh we're GNA play this on
friendly
uh uh yeah Alex go
ahead
um okay let me uh
uh let me adjust the game audio a little
bit bring that
down uh live
gamer
okay apply pre-order Bon bonuses yes new
game
uh what I okay do we want a recap of the
events leading up to
this yeah I'm playing on friendly I'm
not trying to play this on hard
mode playing this for
fun like I am absolutely playing this
for fun
oh it says change my my bit rate to
23500 one of the great things about
having 10 gig internet is there's like
no limit to how fast you can live
stream okay you guys say yes all right
hey Pete I'm working on a college
application and it says I got to tell
them about myself more like sell
yourself it's the worst you got any
advice well take me hi I'm Peter Parker
I'm 25 years old I have a bachelor's
degree in biophysics and I'm in love
with the greatest woman
ever humble brag who is the best
journalist in this city word go MJ I try
to live up to the example set by the
other greatest woman ever this game
looks humble brag again damn and a while
back I was bitten by a radioactive
spider and got super Powers I can't put
that in my essay hey I'm laying the
track as I drive the
train I've used my powers to help the
city and stop a lot of people who wanted
to hurt it like my mentor Dr Otto
Octavius his lab got shut down by an old
colleague Norman Osborne OT retaliated
by releasing a
bioweapon in the end I managed to stop
Otto but not without great cost that was
pretty good but I'm no Peter Parker
exactly you're Miles Morales you're 17
years old and a student at Brooklyn
Visions Academy what else I guess I help
out with my mom's work in Harlem every
now and
then she's councilwoman Rio
Morales and there is a girl I like who's
spectacular and inspiring and I think is
one of the best artists in the
city and I
also got bitten by a radioactive spider
that gave me superpowers I learned how
to be a Spider-Man from the
OG but I learned how to be a hero from
my
dad he was killed by Martin Lee in the
city hall
bombing the good I try to do every day
is the good my dad planted in me but
it's been hard even with superpowers
sometimes we can't save the people we
love
no matter how hard we
try a hero is someone who doesn't give
up though and I don't plan
to I don't know man I can't talk about
me without talking about
Spider-Man sure you can you just have
to
uh yeah why don't you just start another
draft ma'am I'm so excited to play this
game here's a here's a question is the
soundtrack as dope in this as it was in
Spider-Man Miles Morales CU that
Spider-Man Miles Morales soundtrack was
dope God it was so dope it was like one
of the best soundtracks
[Music]
ever they were really
good look at my
boys be ready
are you
good promise me
something
anything if this doesn't
work take me
out it'll
work I don't have a lot of time
left I want a chance to say
goodbye
soundtrack goes hard I'm not going to
lose
you I will never let you
go
what
bro what what is going on
[Laughter]
what
wow we have a bell for a
reason take your
seats I mean that was crazy
right I'm here
good morning class we have a new hold on
you said put the game in performance
mode how do you do performance
mode yeah I don't know how to put the
game in performance
mode teacher joining us
[Music]
today hi my name's Pete Mr Mr Parker uh
and we are all very lucky today because
this is physics class and physics is
awesome ever wonder how some insects and
uh birds reptiles can just run right
across pond oh is it under
visuals
settings
visual hdr's
on I think I turned on
where
is yeah like there's 120 display mode
but I don't see performance
mode yeah I don't see performance here
unless I'm
blind
yeah I don't see
that oh okay
so I probably can't oh I probably can't
do it during
AEM
bathroom okay
okay wait till after the cut
scene now surface tension is all about
cohesion now in equation for tension
gamma can be calculated as the force
exerted parallel to the surface of a
liquid is that Sandman F divided by the
length L of the line over which force
act can anybody uh
I I I need your help
uh Mr Morales is it uh are you sure this
isn't something you can handle yourself
I'm
sure it's sand man son FN Marco class uh
re chapter 4 or five or whatever miles I
need this job if the principal comes
back and sees I'm gone I'm going to get
fired I know but you got to see
[Music]
this
Marco why
[Music]
today I'm so getting
fired I forgot how all the controls work
[Music]
FYI
okay so you guys said to set the visual
go to
visual Fidelity
performance sure apply and restart the
last checkpoint right what's our last
checkpoint
[Music]
wow about to take it
live already hates me for being late
this morning bro I told you to be on
time it's fine we'll be back before we
know it good cuz I have my college
application man I'm swinging alongside
miles
baby haven't started I love Miles
Morales let's get to the city and take
care of Marco
[Music]
quick I don't know what
I'm
[Music]
hey guys you might want to get downtown
fast Bruce thanks for the superat man
Jam have you on the ground for the bugle
still can't believe old Triple J is your
new
boss really loving the new regime you'll
whip him into shape in no time wait the
web what is the up Marco been years
since our last Showdown according to
Witnesses he was running down Broadway
yelling nonsense they say he seemed
angry and paranoid
delusional he just exploded he was mad
cuz I wasn't covering D Cal him down
I've seen people lose control like this
be careful good thing there too
Spider-Man now good luck thanks MJ might
need the new tech we've been cooking up
too no way they're untested barely
prototypes but you brought them right no
comment man he's over here throwing
rocks and caring on bro
the game's good man the game's really
good I'm over here about to jump with
the propellers of this
helicopter now here's a question man how
do we fight sand like I don't even know
how we fight
that spraying with
you okay yeah but I think we found him
do they still have those whoa
Spiderman what the that Sandman MJ
wasn't kidding we got to help him before
he hurts someone or himself
Jesus maybe he's hungry oh to toss the
big guy bad job this time we got to stop
watch I'm going to turn around and die
on friendly
mode he's winding up
bro let's send that debris right back to
him Spider-Man
open wide
okay so Sam man is really difficult like
he's just keep him busy I got an idea I
hope
so God he's enormous that's what
she he is colossal man still angry after
all these years Marco you should try
yoga he's
like
must be more of a Pilates
guy that was your idea never said it was
a good
one it was supposed to be a normal day
get out of here man physics have awkward
conversations in the teacher Lounge ho
cow use the stairs
everyone oh do they still have those
where like you can let people die
sign for this delivery like if you're
negligent somebody will like somebody
will die cuz I'll be honest man there
were times I just want like I would let
people
die his eyes get really big and he's
like kind of thing I could do that
oh here we go son son son Let's Get It
On baby down not before he bared on my
suit for a ride on the Pain Train boy
Sandman just ped out some new friends
what the he can do that apparently need
you
now get wrecked son I'm sorry who's this
prinipal Evans call down the Thunder and
now you got Evac their where are
you look I didn't get I didn't get
touched once I didn't get touched once
not one time not one
time what was that nothing I'm
just oh yeah
oh my God Son M son son son
son it work I mean uh I'm just running
back right now get back here and
supervise your students or else that
does not sound
good almost there how you holding up up
miles Evans called
oh God look at this am I getting
expelled hey you're just cutting class I
abandoned students during a Citywide
emergency wre yeah you're
screwed
oh I forgot how fun these games are man
this is just good oldfashioned
fun Z man relax I'm playing all friendly
I always hated that name oh damn I know
you're angry me this has nothing to do
with you leave me
alone I want to help
you oh he's going to drop the water on
him yeah man water was his
weakness this game is gorgeous oh my
God
wait did I forget
to oh okay I thought I died I thought I
was supposed to spress Circle or
something happy to
reconnect a nostalgic type yeah Sam man
looks really
good or I'll kill you damn he's not
listening we got to turn it up a notch
ow he hates water his shoulders already
wet oh I'm playing this miles right now
electricity Nei my mind
boom yes oh damn miles that's what I'm
saying son that's what I'm saying miles
getting that damage in getting that good
damage in I'll keep the water flowing in
the meanime damn he's s fleeing for his
life here I come here I come Flint came
around for round
two oh no no come on it's okay it's
okay webs will keep them
busy he's done take your shot
fire oh that do somebody order some
water Tak him on the Pain Train the Pain
Train
[Music]
son oh damn oh H threw him across the
city man okay I'm working on it you
threw him like two
miles
damn thought I lost you there can't get
rid of me that easy Oh I thought I work
his magic Yi you there dude this is nuts
I know man but listen we need a big
water source by Wall Street let me check
the grid stay safe dude you too Mr
Parker we'll
do wait what he knows geny knows
all we were super weird in class earlier
I knew I never should have taught at A
Gifted
school I can get up close
now here it
com oh I got to heal got to heal okay
I'm about to die on friendly mode the
easiest mode in the game and I'm going
to turn around and get myself
killed time for a face of face there we
go this is better than the king
beginning
of oh we're about to shock him in the
face look B
in the face in the face guys the water
tank on the ma building should do the
trick 10,000 G here thank you hangover
thanks G oh thank
you second half of the game should have
stayed away
spiders don't think we got him right
where we want
him I admit I may have spoken too soon I
love that warning system with the spider
he definitely getting
bigger keep climbing we're so
close there we
go dude's got like diamonds in his
head
miles come on Miles get up
man
oh I just wanted to live normal family
friendly like everyone else this isn't
the way Marco
for a guy like me there is no other
way oh here we
go Venom
punch this is getting out of
hand Peete what happened I ended up
outside just keep going up I'll meet you
the roof come on baby T are only shot
yes yes
[Music]
yeah oh really oh wait a minute I pulled
down the water okay cool I keep
forgetting about the environmental
aspects where you outside just throw St
stay inside Jeffrey Murray let me tell
you something going to be a long day if
we don't get that water tank there's my
best man let me tell you something oh
bro keep it moving
mouse okay so I have to go oh this way
okay so I got to crawl down through
here in life you can still have one it's
too late now bro if you don't stop
talking miles man he knows where you're
at because you're talking oh
yes come on in
baby
boom yes that's what I'm saying
come on in baby the water is high
cast
yeah come on everything okay almost PE I
know you're on every channel I'm heading
downtown to help coordinate me ources
and supplies oh I forgot that Rio knows
that he's uh got this meeting with my
counselor later and princi think I can
talk to your principal but New York
needs you right now coolest mom ever and
please be
careful there we go yeah like M said
can't let New York
down Get
Wrecked fire that's what I'm saying son
that's what I'm saying
oh that's what I'm saying boy wor for
yourself
Marco that's what I'm saying I don't
care oh thought there was a guy behind
me oh
crap thought there was a guy behind
me look at that look at you see that
about this for my quick legs get into
any college I wanted or Spider-Man
would that's what I'm saying later
Focus man you better come strong that's
what I'm saying look at
this they don't
understand look at they they were not
prepared how's it going look at almost
there the water Tank's ours really like
that's that's that's your big move
actually it's his
Now read the chat since playing the game
hey sorry what I
miss to eat
me let's give him a drink
instead
oh did we do
it
nope man we
done we don't just
[Music]
small break out the new toys the suit's
last software patch wasn't stable but
here goes nothing what's the new
toys web Wings yes yes web Wings they're
flying but we're not out of this yet
Marco's at Pier 4 Beach what happens if
he get Wing son we can fly he just did
yes going to need you ASAP miles yeah I
see him all right I'm right behind
you oh
wow I guess we have some Dodge
stuff what did I just get myself into oh
crap oh I was like man I'm about to
die about to fly into a building calm
down Marco innocent people are in danger
you care about them but not
me that's cuz you're over here killing
people Marco but they can't ignore
Sandman be running around kill
people What
happened is that Electro no
way miles one and only oh man man I was
like please tell me Electro is not going
to show up son that would that would be
pretty
dope yeah glass is back in session class
is back in session son today's lesson
how to take that assle Marco storm is
generating a lot of electricity
Professor is what happens to the surface
tension of sand if you turn up the
voltage
yes you'll be pleased to know ladies and
gentlemen class is in I'll shoot it
right at it you want me to get hit by
lightning can you handle it only one way
to find
out coming
in oh my God the double team
bro damn yeah look at this look at
this you guys are learned a very
valuable lesson when you mess with a
bull get the
horns bro how exactly are you going to
redirect the lightning like you said I'm
coming for you
son
yes yes hell yeah that's what I'm saying
babe oh oh it's like that huh
oh you put hands on get that ass
whoop CCH your beat
down
that you beat down the likes of which
never boom look at that
fun I'll punch that dude into Oblivion
Spider-Man time to
move why won't you just give up because
to protect this
city man I'm I'm loving the team up
between these two guys
man why do it keep getting struck by
lightning is it just like thunderstorms
like what is
this oh snap an electrified
[Music]
mil you got this miles going all silver
serent
light
oh oh
son
[Music]
oh start doing that in the comics do
that in the comics
[Music]
son
calm down the
Hulk that was pretty dope I have sand
everywhere it only gets
better
[Music]
man Marco is going to be
okay I haven't been
okay for a long time he's the most emo
guy ever all you have to do was
ass that was very
awesome I haven't been okay you are the
ones who are going to need
help when they come for
you come for
us I'd love to hear him like shout from
the distance did I
stutter God they they did a great job
with Sandman just showing how dangerous
Sandman is they did an amazing
job oh what's this
Craven Heathman gaming thanks our
supplier is actually they went out of
business we don't have any more rour
rings to give away but uh send me an
email I'll have two custom rings made
for
you you grow slow in your old age s
s a fate you will not
share that's not C that's crazy there we
go I have been in your Shadow for hours
but you sense
nothing
pathetic
great that looks so
D I asked for an
equal and this is what you
find
sir perhaps a new hunting ground Craven
and the Craven
Nets that needs to be a
band
Riley hey thank you yeah I appreciate
that thanks should being a
fan your late start over no that ain't
going to happen light the
fires the great hunt begins a great
hunt that was a long
intro that was the longest intro I've
ever
seen yeah Craven's
gigantic yeah
insomnia's Wolverine's going to be crazy
Pete you seeing
this hold on I take
miles it's been a long day y am I
allowed to to yawn on live stream is
that like going to be safe is that bad
for him to yawn on
[Music]
stream it's like yeah The Unofficial
rules gke I know I know the whole City's
Telecom network is down what's happening
to the requests that are coming in
they'll all get cute but wait uh I'm
going to try a work around work fast get
it together
[Music]
gkey right before the app went down I
saw a request for help at Liberty and
Broadway so I've heard headed there now
that the city is like twice the size
that it was
before what a
mess Marco what got into you like it's
it's more realistic in comparison to
have New York
City I've got you hold
on hell she could have just asked any
one of like the firemen who were around
why why did I respond to that Spider-Man
Chief needs your help hey any one of you
15 people that are walking this way do
you guys mind helping me pull this guy's
body out of the ground so he doesn't
die oh dude did I hit that need figure
sidewalks I was trying to punch her get
out of here news guy
hey what up
y'all Spiderman
[Music]
Spiderman just being obnoxious on camera
okay
is a craven movie in the M verse the mor
verse I hope not
man this is
awesome I think Sony has an amazing idea
by focusing on villains every focusing
on got a call with and the line cut out
we got to get through to set up Triage
on it
Chief
Markiplier welcome to un Till
Dawn I wish I had Markiplier's voice
that guy's got an amazing
voice uh oh we
go that did
it uh Mr Parker I need your help to get
the app back online what do you need the
roof of the building on worth and
Lafayette what's the plan it's going to
be hours before the Telecom networks
back up so we're going to create our
Network that's a big job how long have
you been planning this well dreaming
about it since seventh grade but
planning uh for the last 2 minutes or
so there we go I'm starting to get the
hang of the wedding can you still run up
buildings oh yes you
can there should be a launcher around
there what is all this stuff
environmental study by a new startup the
launcher is for high altitude weather
sensors and this startup G was Horizon
labs in the other in the I check with
the head guy super nice seemed excited
about helping out
Spider-Man what am I supposed to
do here we go okay tell me what to do
you still got that 3D printer built into
your web shooters right I need you to
build something real quick just sent you
the
blueprints got them oh one of the guys I
saved looked like Markiplier oh
okay this looks like a drone we don't
spy on people gkey oh no no no get to
level 20 to unlock a s the app which
gets routed through these drones which I
call focused relay neighborhood data
spots FN D I don't know can I get
arrested make a friend you did wait are
these the uh so wholesome these are the
doctor occup Spider Box how do we get
this thing
Airborne there's a lot of competing
signal traffic so try to follow the path
I marked on your visor it'll give us a
clearer
signal Superman 64 is that
you
damn
wow local network should be online that
thing moves fast notify the app
users if there was a
biggest from the comics that hasn't been
shown in the movies what would it be
um we did it let's
see back in
[Music]
business I don't
know I mean I want to say like Hulk
versus Sentry but like we're going to
get that like we're going to see that so
oh little GIF I already knew about
that little GI is like I'm GNA post a
spoiler little does he know it is not a
spoiler at all that guy's an
idiot oh chain skill trees
okay
uh Spider Whiplash an attack that lifts
multiple enemies into aerial combat is
selected spend your skill point to
purchase the
skill just so you guys know I never pay
attention when I get like a new power
and I hardly ever use it
so um I think you can bounce between the
two
um oh imagine being that miserable I
don't know man if the guy had a life
worth living he'd be outliving it
instead of trolling on the internet I
don't know what to tell him oh wait a
minute
uh oh you can CH oh that's
dope oh and then you can do skill trees
based on the two of
them air throw them and bounce them off
the
ground
oh that's
dope okay should I stop spending money
on on
skills Whiplash is a pretty good skill
okay
uh isn't there a comic where Yoda lifted
a giant minigun and absolutely
annihilated an army of droids I don't
know man but if there was I need to read
it cuz Yoda with a Minun sounds
amazing do I have any more volume on my
microphone
yeah is my microphone volume too low do
I need to turn it
up oh save it okay
cool yeah wolver Wolverine turning in a
ghost rider was a really really cool
idea um would I like to see a Wolverine
versus movie crossover yes I thought you
were asking if I want to see a crossover
I'm like there is a crossover happening
like right
now save skill points
okay
[Music]
uh okay save skill points I will save my
skill points crime report just came
in web
Wings tell me why it is every time I see
web wings I think
my mic volume is low we got plenty of
time okay how about now L better stand
let's clear this place
out come on load him up oh if there a
Legends comic okay that makes sense he's
here smash
him stealing weapons not on my watch
this Spider-Man wrecked whose idea was
it to have a gun club in the
city
I think I'm going to start I mean how is
that not all the gun clubs with
something
better like a compliment Club
compliments don't hurt anyone and
they're
free don't down for example you take a
punch really well good
job hey I think I'm on to something I
that's what I want to know man I feel
like like uh this isn't much just want
to say thanks oh dude yeah nothing don't
worry about it man yeah I I appreciate
that I mean Super Chat is there but it's
not by any standard of measurement like
a like a
necessity that was a big crew I mean
just just like being a fan watching
City's covered in sand yeah that's more
than that wish I knew what got into
Marco more of them coming let's give him
a warm welcome Punisher versus John Wick
who wins Punisher hands down it's not
even a contest today is a good day Rob
is streaming and Magic the Gathering is
doing a crossover with Marvel I was
never a magic the Gathering guy but yeah
okay so um navigate to upshoot
gadget do I have to buy this thing or
can I just skip out of it oh no I have
to
damn okay tune
logic okay
uh wait what do
I
unaffordable
okay I don't know what I just bought I
don't manam what is
this damn boy they came Loaded for Bear
yeah it's one of my superpowers
[Music]
okay
so oh that's dope my app is still down
no trying to innovate here give me a
minute I'll call you back really you
going to shoot Spider-Man you think he's
mad at me stress masquerades his anger
sometimes just keep looking for people
to help now you sound like you're angry
I'm not angry miles just focused that's
what my mom always says when she's angry
come on you've known me for a long time
what have you ever seen me angry okay
this is getting a little rougher than I
thought it would be it was a rhetorical
question got it that one time we were
playing a board game that your place and
you kept losing I wasn't angry at you I
was angry at the
universe I'll take you
down man why are you pointing a gun at
me
son help bam
boom
wrecked what superhero superpowers lend
themselves for good gameplay potential
um O Okay the new app is compiling I
figured as long as we're at it we might
as well give it an upgrade we don't need
anything fancy we just obious a whole
Arkham Asylum series while the patch is
updating we should widen the net te
would be a really good game that would
make for a really good game
um some of the deals with like mystery
like Adventure travel different things
like
that
um I can't think of a Marvel Superhero
that's similar to like Tomb Raider like
lar Croft or like Nathan dra and
Uncharted
um I mean what would be a superhero that
would
blue Marvel would be
good Nightcrawler would be fun but his
teleporting would get old pretty fast
Daredevil would be
cool uh a little sum for my favorite
YouTube love you Rob thank you
Joe
uh oh Jeff thanks for coming out man
yeah I appreciate it Rob's token yeah I
mean is there like an adventurer type I
mean I can't think of an adventure type
comic book
character I mean I'm also kind of tired
so my brain's not
runninga miles you busy what do you need
get to the roof of that building
[Music]
nearby cable would be cool sin is pretty
close to Lovecraft
um Elsa Bloodstone is pretty similar to
that too Elsa Bloodstone would make a
great game the problem is just giving
giving people a reason to carear about
it look you got a superhero
jump yo you son is stressed earlier you
doing okay yeah there's just a lot going
on and I'm hungry and the vending
machine only has those plain low sodium
table crackers oh man that sucks I'll
manage hey so I'm finally doing that app
upgrade I've been talking about with the
Little Help from My
Friends that's that's a brilliant pun
that doesn't make sense to you yet got
it will in a minute oh that's cool dive
to gain speed I dig
this imagine if Insomniac miles
fights 1610 oh ultimate 1610 miles who
do I think would
win oh yeah PS5 miles would dest destroy
Ultimate Universe miles just cuz he's
he's got more experience and yeah he's
just more
capable I mean here's the question do
you guys think they're going to do
another spiderverse event because of the
popularity of the PS5 Spider-Man games
and Spider-Man into the spiderverse
because like into of the spiderverse
came out after the original spiderverse
event from back in the day so I could
see them like doing another spiderverse
Centric event except like a good one one
instead of like the crappy one death the
spider BST whatever it was okay and um
here there should be a launcher
somewhere around there and then bringing
in PS5 Spider-Man or PS5 maybe it's
under the
sand a cable in Deadpool game uh I don't
know how I'd feel about
that fall damage exists okay cuz you
could just like Fall For Eternity and
just be
fine oh just using
the you're going to 3D print a
friend 3D print a
friend BR chick B I get it now brown
chicken brown
cow let me guess friendly relay Network
drone close but it doesn't really matter
what matters is that it uses spatial and
temporal correlated yeah the issue with
the spiderverse stuff in terms of what
they're doing with Spider-Man is the the
first sperse was so
popular Marvel Marvel's Marvel started
Marvel doing it all time do you guys
know the history about why Marvel does
that like white crossover events happen
all the
[Music]
time this drone is kind of crazy okay
local network is
connected
oh you can enable fall
damage new crime report I see it on my
way you just want to see null yeah
man oh I love miles Wings man that
red damn that's clean as hell have you
guys seen those uh those miles Adidas
for um spider at the gun club got to
move before he gets they look so clean I
want to get a pair man but they're like
hundreds of dollars hey need a
hand
uh lost your keys there's a locksmith up
the
street I'll rip your limbs off spider
okay these guys move a lot
faster seems like
Overkill What If instead of stealing you
I don't know tried to help rescue
people man I'll be honest with you guys
like like I would I would be a straight
up bad
guy you don't want
this are you okay yeah like when I
played uh n Old Republic first thing I
did was play the dark side oh you met
with Mr s uh
no Spider-Man is going to get you in
college I'll make it Ma promise got to
run this bring in the big guns big
guns guys got like a 45 you about to be
in a big gun that's not a knife this
is holy cow
oh this
hor big boy all right big
boy Let's Dance
I can be a physic class right now
memorizing abstract equations for
hypothetical
situation Escape now I think I like this
kind of physic
better that guy
sucks is there another guy over here
you're going to win this that guy was
not paying one bit of
attention sh the SP F that's
bad dude the combat system in this is so
much better than it used to
be it just feels smoother am I the only
one am I the only one who feels that way
the combat sy just feel smoother in this
game more intuitive more fluid if
anything okay the app's finally updated
check it out re working on merch at the
moment yeah miles miles poers a
camouflage that would be really
fun uh Eminem
Spidey yeah yeah I feel like it's the
the combat system is a lot more
intuitive than it used to
be still got work to do oh wait a minute
oh swipe left
oo nice work new request just came
in our office is on fire gkey nice work
on the app this will help a lot of
people thanks miles let's hit these last
requests and get back to
school I want to try the fall damage by
the way save us
I mean what would a Green Lantern game
even look like to be honest Crystal I'll
check it out thank you that Crystal's
back there we didn't touch
it the crystal the crystal back here
what is
this it's like an incron
[Music]
Crystal Ultimate Alliance was a what the
hell
oh
didn't we just whoop you you still here
Marco oh that's miles it's MJ just
checking in I think I'm finding stman
again did he escape already no I'm at
the raft he's right in front of me but I
have a hunch sit tight let me talk to
his
doctor oh wow okay I can dig that okay
now you pissed me
off oh the Venom smash God I loved that
okay I talk to the doctors is there a
sand Crystal thingy near you yes okay
the doctors say Marco's mind is broken
literally shattered into freaky oh so
why are these sand dudes attacking me
probably bits of his subconscious trying
to protect whatever's in that Crystal
but listen if you can find all all the
pieces they say you might be able to
make him whole again being a St person
sounds complicated to oh is if we make
him hole does he like spill the beans on
a bunch of
stuff okay Marco what was your
subconscious
protecting maybe this computer monitor
will tell
us
one minute I was with you and the
next you were gone talking
Crystal okay oh that's cool okay so this
is like is this like a side mission so
like grab all those little those little
crystals MJ said that there were more
crystals scattered around the city got
to keep an eye out okay so it is awesome
hey you want to grab that last request
looks like some VIP stuck in a limo on
it I don't give a damn some VIP in a
limo Yankee is Mr T still there yeah
he's with Haley right now she's trying
to stall him for you nice hopefully he's
going to tell me how to write my college
essay you're not done with that yet you
know since I already got into ESU I
could help you nah hold on what was your
uh too much
already I didn't get any colle you never
shut up about it um yeah that's true oh
your Super Chat hold on a second let me
see I think I missed
it oh Rob cor ring or any merch yeah we
don't we're not able to do robc corn
Rings anymore because our vendor went
Belly Up um merch we're currently
working on
so let's
see
how do I feel about this sonye in the
games where MJ works for bugle Peter is
mainly a scientist an a May and Miles
dad are
dead
uh I think that's pretty interesting
yeah I mean I think it's
cool you bursting out laughing you just
got your copy
today yeah Darude
dude
this is all just pandemonium here got
Focus people need my
help I mean they might need your help
miles but I'm swinging
man now is it true that you can you can
fast travel
anywhere like to any particular location
stay away from that limo it's the spider
get him yeah I just started the
game Patrick baitman just like you just
started the
game oh I love this swing
kick paparazi is bad enough oh love
that yall are the worst you know
that these webs are too strong why can't
we all just let people be
people
man you can't catch
me fire the Target
baby get me out get me
out I love how agile God I I this combat
system is so much more fluid than it was
before I love
it
um oh you have to progress in the
district
okay trust old Patty baitman to be the
psycho okay
uh oh this right
here I mean you couldn't just like climb
out through the
back
where's this guy
at that guy looks
dead I mean what do you guys think he's
dead he looks dead to me man gu looks gu
looks dead as a door nail
curtains yeah that dude's
dead okay uh
is there something else that I'm
supposed to
do what am I supposed to do
here
oh oh okay I supposed to like get him
out of the car
okay Hospital
J Jonah Jameson oh it's J Jonah Jameson
leave him for dead that guy's a
dick like you know what Jonah we're just
going to stuff you back in the sand I
I'd push the car back into the sand all
right Mr Jameson let's get you to the
hospital how you going to be a jerk and
ask somebody for help you got to come
see who the VIP in the limo was I
shutter in anticipation cing a hydrant
then I'm on my way Mr Jameson it's
Spider-Man you with me flying in your
Peter's going to realize his Jameson
he's going to be like put that guy
back where am I
[Music]
[Laughter]
Spiderman what no I I'm helping you man
someone get a photo with this Mass
criminals kidnapp beloved newsman
something things never change just be
nice to the bro is that JK Simmons
voicing uh
Jameson
JK Simmons is like the J Jonah Jameson
man they kidnapped me I did not consent
I I oh that's not that's not J I'm
surrounded by menaces uh just wanted to
say Jamon is not going anywhere what I
do matters and please never stop been
around since I was just marvel with the
mini afro wow you are OG
Darth you've been watching for like a
decade man
Mr Parker where are you the man's of men
hi yes this what is a failed and or
forgotten franchise Marvel Comics that
love to see them Rebo I'll be there soon
I promise um as in the concept was cool
but the writing and timing were just bad
new
universe new universe was amazing back
in the day it was
great I can't believe I just did
that that's not him
okay
where's oh R from OverWatch okay oh he
just left something about going on
vacation yeah this whole crotchety
man what that girl that girl paintings
were dope man her graffiti work while
you were gone dope I found out that I
got the Rand scholarship are you serious
yeah bro that's is in the who's I show
speed big day for
everyone give you more star missing out
oh man I can't watch
this but I also can't look away
principal Evans yeah guess who decided
to show up today I I know this looks
terrible looks I'm I'm so sorry it's
more than looks no I know I know I know
I know and this is the last thing that I
wanted to happen and it'll never happen
again I've had enough of this no I look
no more excuses your job is to protect
these students not to abandon them Jonah
sounds like Mr wow man he got
canned po Peter Parker got
sacked
dude you being Spider-Man it must be so
hard keeping a job oh MCU reboot
definitely but I'm sure that you're
going to figure it
out
[Music]
uh yeah I don't really play games on
like I I don't really play them like for
the difficulty that never really
interested me I just want to like enjoy
the game like I'm like 39 years old man
like the days of of sweating and gaming
is just that's not my thing anymore
unless it's Destiny then I'll sweat in
Destiny raise the Savage Oh my God it's
razor The
Savage hey sorry about the job you you
weren't the worst teacher we've ever had
if that helps think I can put that on my
resume well listen there's an open photo
call at the New York bulletin I just
sent a shot in yesterday it's not much
money but it's money that's Robbie
Robertson's paper we used to work
together at the bugle I think I know
just what he'd like thanks miles no
problem I might send him a few more
shots too if I had it's front line in
this game he always said don't show me
the city show me New York cuz that was
if I remember correctly front line was
the Sally Floyd Ben urri comic from
Civil War didn't they launch it during
Civil War like the introduced
Frontline cuz I remember they had a
Frontline comic during Civil War and it
was amazing it was like one of the best
it was like one of the most slept on
comics in the entirety of Civil War cuz
it gave you like the perspective of the
event from like just a regular person
from like a reporter and not any of the
superheroes so you got to see like all
the collateral damage and
the people who were suffering because
Iron Man and Captain America couldn't
get their together like it was cool
man oh he's going to he's going to bust
up there something wait is that Captain
America
shield wait does do the oh that's right
the Avengers do exist they had Avengers
Tower I forgot about
[Music]
that
there now to submit
and Peter how you doing son Robby hi I
know this is out of the blue but I
wanted to let you know I just sent in a
photo for your open call wonderful we
can definitely run this I got I would
love to be a photographer like a like a
photo journalist my way or like a
documentary photographer that would be
dope you too Robbie
thanks Spider-Man limited Infinity comic
from this year uh I heard yeah I heard
they were bringing it either they were
bringing it back or they brought it in
the infinity Comics are okay they're
very very hit and miss like sometimes
they're great and other times they're
just like when in the hell was Marvel
thinking
like who are they helping by making this
comic like who asked for this right so
it can it can be very much a mixed bag
love the videos I love the story line
it's great so far where you're at that's
awesome uh there's a reference to new
New York City based Heroes
okay
um as somebody who plays with discs this
is
painful
okay yeah know I don't give a damn
okay locate Citywide
activities I wonder if the Developers so
Spider-Man's like taking pictures I
wonder if the
developers put like Easter eggs like
adult stuff so you can like crawl up a
wall and like there's some couple who
were just like going at it Spider-Man's
like taking pictures of them posting on
the
internet like Spider-Man What's your
deal I mean it sounds pretty shady to be
honest
wait how do you pull up your
camera how do you pull up the camera I
should go to the top of fist Towers you
heard there's something there he won't
say what
[Music]
okay Louis yeah thank you thank you for
watching how do I feel about the
Ultimate Universe returning I think it's
a great
idea hold on where is Fisk Tower
fist
Towers that's not fist Tower is
it hold on which one was fist Tower I
can't
remember oh swipe up on the
touch oh here we go my suit is Sandy in
all the wrong places might be time for a
change
don't mind me just a friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man creeping on you
guys really you can't just take you
can't take a picture of whatever you
want to take a picture of that
sucks open world Ultimate Alliance would
be
amazing what if Spider-Man was scared of
spiders I'll one up you on that what if
Spider-Man was made of
spiders
man let's go over
here yeah so I've heard that the side
missions in this are absolutely awesome
like they're they're in some cases more
fun than the main story I don't know how
true that statement is
but I guess maybe it's just
relative like I was never much of like a
side quest guy
so does he still have the ability to
swing oh he can
swim am I really gliding off the
water
is that is this for
real so that just
happened yeah that's that just happened
hold on you can surf
what
[Music]
how do you
surf if you press R3 you can see the
wind tunnels around this oh
okay looks like one of Marco's memory
crystals miles told me about I should
check it
out let's go find the memory crystals
where' the memory Crystal go oh I'm on
top
of thought I'd see let's beat up the
Sandman stand in my boots in my gloves
this a
nightmare there we go
all right crack let's crack this guy's
mind open let's break his
mind go to the water while moving fast
and then just hit the
water time to check out that Crystal
someone's watching us Kia
but I don't want you to
worry that's my job Marco thought he was
being
watched who's Kenia I always feel like
somebody's watching
me somebody's watching
me all right
um let's explore the city a little
more let's go take vois pictures of
people
wait what was
that what is
[Music]
this can I not access this
yet oh
Tech throughout the city Tech huh
without the tinkerer they were picked
apart like
vultures I'll let miles know what kind
of capture card am I using I am using
the uh a media 4K Pro
thing okay uh yeah let's go take some
more pictures of people let's go creep
on individuals in
society
hold on was there another thing over
[Music]
here one of the things I did love were
like the stealth
missions this is like a straight up
Manara
pick oh okay so as a street photographer
you want to like we would want to take
this
shot St again probably like this if you
take it like that it's boring because
it's just directly headon I guess it
makes it easier but you want you want
the the viewer to feel like they're part
of the crowd can I take it back right
so come on man you can't take it like
this cuz it obscures the chest board
although is kind of a cool shot you want
to get a view of what's going on so I do
this instead something like night yeah
I'm going to keep that one yeah that's
perfect you know I saw an old grandm
playing there last week okay anyone
could walk up and
Challenge and he lost to a kid oh I
totally forgot about the web
Wings never seen
anything
yeah man I completely forgot about the
web
wings I mean okay so how many of you all
actually live in New
[Music]
York
oh that's
dope you really can
surf oh that's
cool
damn oh
wow oh so this is this is kind of like a
tunnel that like gets you to the other
side oh that's awesome it's like a
transit
system I love
this okay so for those of you guys who
are from New York how accurate
is how accurate is this game to like the
scale of nework
City to New York's finest
hus
why am I not playing as miles hold on
how do I switch back and forth between
them wait you can switch back and forth
between
them
yeah I heard the superior Spider-Man
suits in this I don't know oh
cool I can also style new
suits
um
oh wait a yellow suit okay that's
cool oh is this the Assassin's Creed
arach knite suit yeah
man that's
dope go to the menu go to the app and
you can switch
oh
okay
hey MJ hey I'm headed to your place to
drop something off is the back door
unlocked I don't know left in a hurry
this morning I'll just meet you there
okay cool you and Miles get back to
school okay yep yep quite a first day
for you hopefully tomorrow we'll be
quieter he's going to meet Mary J in the
back door see you in a
bit
uh what's worse than getting fired
telling your girlfriend that you got
fired
okay I kind of like this yellow suit man
it's it's funky and it looks different
but it makes him look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger from the running man but
it's still
cool
oh I cannot switch characters
right oh damn did they buy a house out
here oh moonight
okay he's a flying lemon awful yeah he
looks like a giy banana man really made
a mess seems like you're getting the
hang of that
thing well it is convenient in the city
but it looks lame no it doesn't bike
person convinc me that's D
slaps you're
lame what's
wrong I got
fired you are so excited about this job
no woman reacts like that semer planned
out there's never been an instance where
a man is com home to his girl and been
like I got sacked and she was like I'm
so sorry baby no that's never happened I
might be joining you in the unemployment
line that will never happen Jonah
already cleaning house sort of he's
instituting what do you mean you got
firy what does that even mean it means
that whoever doesn't write a front page
story in the next week where's the red
Peter oh well you'll be fine then
because you're the only fans
have start only fans MJ what you got in
there unsold some caret books running
out of story that's what your
Spider-Man that's fair I sold Spider-Man
gets you a pass nobody wanted to read
about
Saria the bugle is the biggest Outlet in
the city I can make a difference nobody
wants to read about SAR but if I get
fired I don't know what I'll do do you
even need the bugle to do what you want
to do I tried making an impact from the
outside and
copies now I they wasted some of the
slots with the same suit just different
colors like the MCU suits I mean that's
not a terrible
thing I haven't had time to
clean back room yeah you think MJ's
character model looks better than the
game
H I'm just going to only
webs what would a Spider-Man only fan
look like right would he like web
himself
up shake that spider can for a
job wakandans or Amazon
oo pass do amount damn Peter you owe F
$4,700 the hell kind of house that you
have you're paying
$4,700 the house to keep Feast to flat
and now I'm
sinking
bro they're over here $4,700 a
month who gets a mortgage that's $4,700
a month what kind of interest rate do
they have 6.8 well there's a problem
right there 6.8%
interest I bet it's I bet it's a
variable interest rate
loan if Mariah were seeing this she
would just be
like Peter
Peter what's your problem
Peter Mariah if you're watching this
it's exactly what you would
do don't say you
wouldn't 5G is for a
mortgage that's NYC for you yeah that's
fair why do you feel
bricked said brother this is New
York standard standard's not 7%
standard's 8 8.6% right now mortgage
rates are
crazy
like it's it's mortgage rates are insane
right
now just trying man I've been wanting to
play this just need to find the
time the real
commentary you start stealing if you
were Peter oh let me tell you something
man if I had
superpowers speed speed
nagon the hell kind
of the hell kind of game is that I mean
I play it just to see what it
is the teaching thing didn't work out D
wor it's time to toss those bananas man
you got flies buzzing around them and
to be honest I'd like to take some
time off but oh I can't really afford
to what about selling the house I can't
I mean I could but I can't man they got
rotted fruit all in that house I can
cover he's going to S the bowl in the
sink no no I can't let you do that plus
you you said Jonah might clean house I
won't let him fire me I know how much
this house means to you we'll figure it
out I don't deserve
you she going to be like no you don't
Peter and then she's going to leave hey
so have you thought any more about
moving in we talked about this I need to
be in the city close to where the action
is but think of all the romantic dinners
we could have here when was the last
time you were home oh he developed that
game okay fair
point I don't remember
that may and Ben are gone what a shame
yeah yeah don't ever sell Aunt May's
house if they sell Aunt May's house we
Riot we literally turn on
insomnia I feel like I feel like the fan
base would do that right like if they
sold Aunt May's house the fan base would
be like what's your
problem fans get attached to stuff maze
stuff yeah I need to donate it but
not just
yet what are you looking at I mean you
can hold on to pretty cute old photos of
you man I haven't seen these in a while
oh my God Peter I think that was in my
bedroom why did she take a picture of
that balance what does that
mean means balance this is still there
I'm going to go take a
look favorite superhero definitely
Superman I know it's cliche but it's
definitely Superman
any man that says I don't deserve you as
a red flag yeah the gam playay is so
incredibly
smooth balance you find I'm going to
keep looking at these photos you've
never shown
me
adorable this is how you know they're
not a married couple right like if they
were a married couple people would come
Peter he'd come walking into this house
you'd be like hey MJ where you at she's
like I'm in here Chanel toddler Pete's
fashion sense and he would he'd walk in
there he'd be like yeah I see you
looking at pictures I don't smell dinner
cooking where's
dinner oh
man I don't smell nothing cooking MJ oh
recipe book don't worry me here's the
thing I'll keep your wheat cake recipe
alive and well here's the thing about
old ladies man never underestimate the
recipe book of an old woman
honestly I feel like it'd be worth it's
wait and gold to go to like estate sales
and just buy recipe books just collect
them you found fist Towers it's in the
top right of Hell's Kitchen in Manhattan
you heard it's been replaced by another
iconic group's
HQ upstairs there's oh there is an
upstairs man this house is huge that's a
gorgeous house
too I'd remodel it
oh my God look at this place could use
some candles look at this candles are
the least of your concerns man look at
this
pink the pink pink what my God Aunt May
not a damn bit of taste my
God look at his
paintings the bedroom is huge still
smells like
me Dy look at this old
picture hot man no B why does Uncle Ben
look like George W
bush oh
man because never played the first two
games of course I played the first two
games yeah it's it's horribly
ugly get rid of the
pink the recipe recipe books legendary I
mean tell me I'm wrong right like tell
me it it wouldn't be worth it to go to
estate sales just to buy recipe books
like that's what I would do
yeah that bathroom's
[Laughter]
mid why you got to say like that
man this bathroom doesn't
open what's going on what's in that
bathroom what in that
bathroom can't really see what's in
there okay
you ever notice how you do that like
your character's looking through a crack
in the wall in a video game so you're
just
like like you're looking through the
crack oh
man she's a 60-year-old white woman back
then it was the style I don't care man
you gota you got to adapt with the
change in
times walk into A's house like my God a
look at this now that radiator right
there is dope that radiant
heat radiant heat Heat's where it's at
man people underestimate radiant heat
where was that hole
again where was that hole
people I think it'd be cool to have a
house like this okay those of you guys
who are familiar with New York what is
it this is Queens right is that where
Peter is from
Queens oh that's a shot from Amazing
Fantasy 15 Spiderman is he a threat or a
menace lips are sealed Menace definitely
a big fat Menace let me tell you
something about this called superhero
he's neither super nor a
hero was that rify man 100% smells like
mothballs Peter is that old lady smell
oh I uh smells like moth balls and
Chanel I thought I thought I I heard a a
rat in the
wall hey what's what's wrong it's
nothing Forest Hills Queen
okay so Mansion for the space yeah
man when I was your age I was head of
The Debate Club I want to know your all
thoughts man soccer team and a May from
the
PS5 I think she's the best Aunt May out
of all the Spider-Man properties movies
shows my what do you guys but when I
tried to add honor rooll student on
top instead of being good at a few
things I wasn't good at
anything
so I scaled
back balance is a
process not a destination can't afford
all them holes in the
wall I'm still working on that
balance oh come
on oh 100% a Gil yeah come on well not
really a Gil not in my case
but PS5 a May is the
[Music]
goat no I'm not talking about how good
she looks man y'all are weird man she's
like 60 years old I'm saying like I
think she is the best version of Aunt
May I should go check on MJ no if we're
talking about looks alone oh it's
absolutely Marissa to that's not even a
contest it's Marissa to son she's never
not been hot she was hot in the
80s she's not like Jennifer connley who
stopped being attractive like 20 years
ago oh D the size of those glasses yeah
man my my God Uncle Ben looking
good Uncle Ben looks like he look he
looks like he's a really really cool guy
but he'd take you on the Pain Train if
you piss him off just beat the hell out
of
you go mouthing off to
me old ladies can
still yeah I love the idea of feast it
was it was the funniest thing when you
had feast in Marvel Comics because it's
like hey guys here's like a charity
organization we're doing great things
and it's like Mr negative and he's just
like corrupting it and like manipulating
it right he's like embezzling money out
of it it's just like damn what a dick
like how much of a dick would you have
to be to embezzle from a charity fund
like what
a what kind of dick would do something
like that man it was it was hilarious
got a tip raph's moving a couple of
inmates to ravencraft tomorrow for
evaluation they say who no but I'm going
to find
out
MJ whoa doctors haven't cleared me for
MJ hugs yet sorry oh
Harry
why did I think he was Peter Parker at
the beginning of the game I missed you
too I was like Peter looks a little bit
different than I
remember so
sorry so how
was
Europe sorry about all that Mr negatives
in the game as well he's like the
villain that just won't go away he just
kind of lingers in the background doing
stuff sometimes it was past tense we
think it's in
remission B you're hilarious well I'm
sure Benny appreciates that but I'm not
bin you look
great I feel
great you have to get to
work dinner tomorrow is this game worth
getting a PS5 for uh yeah I would say so
far well I don't know if this game by
itself so far I'm not I mean I'm not
qualified to make that decision yet I've
only been playing for like two hours um
but with the other two damn that mot
that's a little skill she picked up when
we were in
Saria sorry for coming by but um with
the other two games are you kidding you
want to come
inside actually I was hoping you might
have time to go for a ride with me
sure I'm surprised the Frugal flyer is
still on the
road I was thinking we might roll like
we used
to lots of villains linger in the
background yeah they kind of do N I
found it on the Internet it's a close
match though right wow yeah like Roder
Kingsley is is a very underused
villain I love R but never really gets
any due diligence
ready are they riding bikes where are we
going we'll see come on try to keep
up why did this turn into an O sure
you're up for this oh yeah I'm feeling
good I was using the cane just for
insurance but I don't even need it you
have more energy than I do so a dick man
what's been keeping you busy I'd like
web up his back tire substitute teaching
in between getting fired make him fall
I've also been tutoring a high school
kid Terrible Special reminds me a little
me actually lucky kid I never would have
passed honor Cal without your
help hey I read about your old boss
nobody's passed calculus without help
must crazy it's calculus that's one way
to put it mathematics in a
threedimensional space I wish you'd been
around Harry that sucks why didn't you
tell me you were sick i' have been there
there in a
shot you wouldn't have liked what we'
seen the treatment was horrible I was
floating in a tank with a healing
agent gave me awful nightmares freaking
symia is what you were doing wow
experimental
stuff wait we're at Midtown high is that
actually where we're going how are they
doing yoga y'all are so
weird I was trying to run him over can
you not run people over on the bike
let's go Pete damn
[Music]
you can't run people over they need to
add some GTA elements to this
game Peter just run up on somebody and
just punch him tell me you're tired come
on punch the hell out of somebody later
just running up on folks putting their
lights
[Laughter]
out I absolutely want to see that
Spider-Man
gameo
oh yeah Harry's like r in the middle of
the road and everything
thanks come on why'd you bring us here
we both hated High School remember that
time Flash oh my God I
rememberer presentation the young
entrepreneurs competition we'd work for
months on that thing and the state meet
was the next morning I had a backup on a
USB but it was in your locker we called
the school begging to let us in but they
said no it was after hours we were so
desperate we walked around the entire
school trying every door until we got to
this
one wait
what I remember we had a Jimmy yet who
breaks into a high
school shall we oh those bikes 100%
getting
stolen they're going to come back to
find those padlocks
cut
mhm ghost is clear come
on you sure the drive is upstairs in
your locker pretty sure what you said
you were sure I was damn these Graphics
look phenomenal what are you asking now
I don't know I'm nervous don't worry
it's
there it's rightfield Rick what's he
doing here on Friday night listening to
the game RB show us that rookie of the
month stuff kid you're going to be on
this team the real queens is ghetto as
hell you were there all summer thinking
no way Peter Parker lives
here FKS there no way Peter lives in
this
place nobody lives in Queens on purpose
just aiming at something
loud too
messy ready to be tackled a runtime
error no we need noise not property
damage
hello
that was a nice defensive play and we're
going to wind up back at the plate with
two outs and the last player in the
or right
here
push nice come
on this is what criminals do am I a
criminal now you're bringing into a high
school to steal a thumb drive man I'm
pretty sure you're far from being a
criminal to tell you I showed our
presentation to my mom she thought it
was really great other news today two
high school students were caught
breaking into Midtown High to steal a
thumb drive they've been sentenced to
life in prison without the possibility
of PE right once we get to the top of
the stairs your Locker's right there
right get
down did he see
us I don't think so split up we'll me
back at the gym hey who's that we're in
trouble we're in trouble
Mayday it does feel like
I'm
[Music]
oh no I'm
out where are you you little
punk someone in here playing tricks
huh
damn I could really use a refill on my
web shooters do we get the drop on the
old man I think I have extra weip fluid
stuff in the photo
lab this is all still kind of new I got
to get better at fluid
management oh I have to go this way
okay get in there
Peter
so where's
his so if the old man catches if
security guard catches you just like
punch him
out the guard is probably dead in real
time oh terrible
man on so is this WB fluid in here this
is the science
swing
okay do a flip how do you do a
flip yeah we can't go anywhere we have
to go this
way
oh wait we can go this way okay
Co drop from ceiling so library to photo
lab photo lab to gym gym to Locker
easy path is clear time to
move what's that
crap hey I really wish I backed this
project picked up online
[Music]
man defitely a kid eating V the spider's
best
friend no such thing as a
ghost okay where did I leave my web
fluid
stuff Peter man I know I put these under
here
somewhere gotcha you still agree with me
most
times
keep moving keep moving stop talking
Peter what's going on J
trous I'm glad you're enjoying it just
right what is this potions
class hello friend
wait so you can make web fluid that's
cool I really should figure out how to
increase the capacity of these things so
I don't run out now to meet Harry at the
gym the gym is on the other side of that
fan got to get past
it
okay old backpack I forgot I put that
here got to start keeping track of these
things man you're killing me
Peter I can't get away from this guy got
to distract him so I can get out of here
Peter got that
[Music]
talk what's that
this is me making a break for
it you can just stay where you are kid
stop running
away this guy man he's got to be getting
terrified I bet Harry's already at the
gym got to hurry we're like terrorizing
this
guy see that's why I couldn't be Miles
Morales with that with his invisibility
Powers cuz I would I would mess with
people and and I would I do things like
God I move him away from that door right
field
[Music]
Rick how do we move him away from the
door uh maybe back through
here
come a spider-like
man
uh okay how do we get this guy away from
the
door sorry for the mess Rick okay now
you can't tell me we don't have a damn
ghost h no ghost just a
[Music]
spider that's
cool I always did like the stealth
missions in the Spider-Man games I
thought you got caught we got to grab
that thundr get out of here let's cut
through the
gym how long is a man get him out in the
same area yeah man it's all coming back
that was crazy he's mopping to finish
off the vinyl this place looks the same
except no security guard
Tails which gives us a minute for some
hoops you sure you're up for this
question is are you let's see it big
talker he sucks Rusty no Bigg har
Osborne sucks at
basketball
you I got this
son look at this
Harry good one boom I am so happy you're
feeling better look at that seriously
thanks get on my level I didn't get a
chance to see what you did with ma house
nothing
yet I've been busy and I don't know
feels weird to change it yeah if I were
like miles man like that must have been
really tough I'd go invisible and then
like somebody's walking through their
house and like I would move a chair out
a little bit so like they stub their
toe yes yeah i' be awful like that maybe
she'll help with the
house I don't know you don't think
she'll help I don't know she'll move in
oh well I mean it seemed like you guys
were doing
good she was at your house we'll figure
it out you always do yeah man Peter's
hardcore styling on
Harry he's like Harry you're like LeBron
in the fourth quarter man it just the
game just just falls apart what's the
score I have no idea me neither the
stock Indie music thanks for bringing me
here I needed this me too Steph Curry
you mean Steph Curry but we're not done
yet I know that look oh with their
powers yeah they could Hustle the heck
out of people still think you can find
your old
Locker where do you think that security
guard is probably still in the East Wing
then let's get that thumb drive out of
your locker and get out of
here oh God I loved life is strange we
got to make flash pay for breaking your
laptop just let it go you can't just let
him get away with it he's captain of the
football team and I'm a backup singer in
GLE Club he's going to get away with it
best is to win that competition
tomorrow like I always hated people who
said that like the best revenge is to
live a fulfilling life no the best
revenge is Revenge like that's the best
revenge quick get under
there that's not true got to get him
back in that
elevator I checked this floor three
times already this is a damn goose
chase somebody in there what's going
on get back in the elevator crazy
man he's
gone got lucky with that one got yeah
quick get the drive and let's
go uh oh here we
go Maguire what is this how did you go
on take it
oh crap who's that nice touch is uh this
guy part of all this too nope
Run is it the same security guard is it
like the same it's the same guy
wow this is not the kind of nostalgia I
like
you still got that thumb drive
yeah just got to make it to those doors
almost there open up it's the
police I called the cop you're in
trouble now go but hold them off for
just a minute I got an idea what should
I do don't get
caught boy har is going to beat him to
death keep
forgetting
police let's
go oh damn he put it in his pocket you
guys are going to have to rough him up
now hey you the one who called us yeah
they're in here somewhere all right you
two spread out while we got this guy's
statement oh I always love these
missions I got to get the guard alone so
I can get the thumb drive back they're
in here somewhere my guys are looking we
need your statement tell me what you saw
well uh rightfield Rick I mean the
School Janitor has been hearing this uh
you know he can be a little funny about
this stuff funny like haha or well he
jumps to conclusions he has some crazy
idea the school has a ghost but it's not
a ghost it's just some fo kids kids more
than one well I don't know for sure but
I suspect distract the police to get
actually alone well have you actually
seen
them not so much but I've heard them how
can you be sure there's more
than check it out let's get this party
started that's one come on boys you know
you're in
here whoa let's take a picture it'll
last
longer nice now I just have to distract
this last guy where's the last where's
this last distraction
at oh here we
go don't move I'll be right
back he's Alone Now for Something I like
to call the upside down
pickpocket what is this these kids
playing tricks
I got time nice nonsense that should put
me right above him's probably waiting up
for me probably made some popcorn got it
what was that bro that was close how am
I supposed to get we almost got
[Music]
caught going to give you up never going
to let you down we got Rick
Roll we got Rick R so
bad we're no strangers to
[Music]
love and so do I we got to hide damn
it's not the
cops is that his dad dad
bro damn they called his whole Dad Dad I
told you I'd call you when I got
home it's your
mother oh what
happened uh Peter would you excuse us
for a
moment oh Peter would you mind your own
business for a
[Music]
moment
copyright be like
[Music]
bro why does Peter look like Harry
Potter Andrew said we have five
stars Harry what is
this you know I still think we would
have won state if we'd presented
lot's happened in the last 10
years it's a miracle I'm even sitting
here
now Harry's mom died of ligma a second
chance ligma what I'm going to take
advantage of
that but I need you with me Pete do I
think the MCU should time Jump soon to
age up to Chara son and why are Dr Doom
and Deadpool the best Marvel characters
ever well I don't know how I feel about
them aging honly I don't think the child
of Sun is going to play a significant
role in the MCU I think they just kind
of like he's got a legacy we talk about
it um but doom and Deadpool well
Deadpool's not the best character in
Marvel Comics but Doom is he's amazing
Pete we're going to heal the
[Music]
world can't watch because you don't want
spoilers that's
fair look my balls
oh I forgot about
Craven I totally forgot about Craven
Strike Force K1 on
approach status report the Mana and
Arena are nearly complete recon units
report
in the Sandman eluded us recapture not
an
option then he was not the
one copy that awaiting order
sir prepare for the transfer
tomorrow and do not fail
again do not fail
again Craven is so cool I love him in
this
game
my name is
Miles
Morales and even I'm bored
already that's actually pretty awesome
to be
[Laughter]
[Music]
honest I'd say it's probably a c you
busy I need whatever it is I'm down need
some help with a babysitting Mission at
the r sounds fun fill me in on the
way he is so bored y'all ever been that
board you just do the first thing that a
friend invites you to do because you
have nothing else to
do thoughts on venomized Magneto wasn't
that in the poisons comic but yeah
that's
cool I love the
[Music]
idea don't give me that look pops only
all right Mac you have a good
one oh
how's the asset going it's it's
going I going to head out though Pete
call for and back up we're just it's
better if I don't know the details I'll
be fine Ma mil's drip got trash now it's
better no it
didn't that hair is not doing many
favors recently where you've been
working late and so I also worked
late well I wasn't
working don't give me that look I'm not
in any
trouble it's just um I've been going on
some dates dating actually oh right and
there's this one guy I've seen him a few
times and it's well it's going
well Rio's out there getting her groove
back I'd like to have him
over
forone I'm sure there's some spider
stuff all right Caleb we have a good one
man I can give you some privacy no I
Cuban Spider-Man yeah didn't they like
patch that they patch the flag but if
you're not comfortable I totally
understand
Ma look you had me at bone who's this
mystery man is what I want to
know that hair is Criminal man that hair
ain't doing him no favors I see you
she's been working
[Laughter]
late uh I don't think I ever played
Spider-Man web with shadows
better head to the
raft should be getting
there m why you been going to the
chiropractor so much well I met a really
nice man and he's been throwing my back
out there's another
one I should catch that up
dra h
who I'm getting the hang of
this this is cool man I can dig this
transit
system yeah I love this I I love this
travel system another updraft I should
check the
view Lev a windy
day hey miles I'm just getting to the
raft you on your way would have miss it
who were babysit MJ got a tip yesterday
that
scorpion not enough resources for him
since Sandman became his roommate
scorpion can definitely throw a tantrum
I'll be
there there we
go well kind of flying into people we
flew into a whole group of
people oh man
man watch your mysterious boyfriend be
Martin
Lee this game has you curious about
Harry Osborne of the comics Harry
Osborne of the comics is he's he's
sometimes he's cool sometimes he sucks
it just depends on the story more
recently he's been pretty interesting
he's been pretty
solid all right guys I am going to call
it it's getting kind of late here and
I'm getting
sleepy hey friends it's
you are listening to the Dan cast get
this now the fastest growing podcast in
New
York that's
cool for you new listeners welcome the
dast is your yeah so I'm going to go
ahead and bounce off here
guys it's cool like this is fun um it
was it was a cool little thing single
the trains running during the sand
attack main be completing the game
tonight no I usually take my time
playing a game like
this
I don't know maybe we'll do it again I'm
not
100% I mean maybe I'll do like a live
streaming Channel like come expl live
streams and just like uh just live
stream playing this game or other games
or something on those lines so anyway
I'm going to bounce off here guys